so you have done a bit of research about
TOEIC there's first we should say TOEIC
of courses test of hey what is it
T Oh English for international
communication or something like that
it's the most commonly used test of
English proficiency
around the world and I think Korea is a
very big country for TOEIC and people
need this test to get a job to get into
university and so forth great so what
did you find it um they changed
horizontally on May I guess in 2016 and
now they have grass and also they have
they usually have dialogue but they've
changed to three people's instead of
just two right they put more questions
about lungs and long paragraphs for one
question especially part seven I guess
six and seven and they reduce some
question on part five which is easier
than six and seven because they want
people study English not just skills
well that was interesting you said that
they believe that this will make it
harder for people to just practice the
test become skilled at writing the test
they're actually gonna have to know
their English yeah I think the proposed
up this changes are bad right you know I
think that's a good thing really I think
torque is a good test because it's not
that expensive like TOEFL is much more
expensive right so it's a good test and
I think the main you know to the extent
that I've looked at toi the main thing
there is that you have to be able to
read fast you have to be able to
understand when you hear like listening
pretension and you need quite a large
vocabulary and so really those are the
main activities that link you know
reading listening and and acquiring
words in context because I often like in
Korea I saw the same thing as I see in
Japan you go in the bookstore just kinds
of books
toach word lists people buy these books
ya go and they try to learn the word
exactly you were saying that the new
test will not only test the knowledge of
do you know what this word means but do
you know how this word is used with
other words and that comes from learning
the words in context so I I think that's
linked would be a great tool for someone
that aren't sure for sure I think so too
yeah because I've tried the previous
talk test before I came here and it was
quite tough because my English level was
that wasn't that high to be really bad
in short time and I need to concentrate
whole like more than two hours and write
quite top for me so I think practicing
reading and this thing is really
important it's it's really good tools
for studying toy writing right
you know I mean there's nothing wrong
with practicing the text the test rather
so people who take the tests young times
are gonna get better at the test that's
yes there's nothing wrong with that you
know we're doing you know mock tests all
that is good but the bigger thing is to
build up your your listening
comprehension skills your reading skills
and I think you know if you buy a book
five thousand words for TOEIC you're
better off to learn those 5,000 words at
link and and having looked at my own
experience in learning Korean and other
languages I think that like right now in
Korean I'm gonna learn 4,000 new words
in a month I think if a person at length
learned 2,000 new words in English 2,000
new words I think every 2,000 words
could well be equivalent to a hundred
points
so if you spend and so in a month if you
learn 2,000 words you might go up 100
points into it so it may be here at 500
you go up to 600 or 600 you officers
have another now 2,000 is a minimum I
think a person can do more than that I I
see no reason why people kind of can't
learn 4,000 words a month using link but
they will learn all of those in context
not sort of as a word list in some book
they buy the bookstore so I think people
should should look hard at link as a
main sort of tool for preparing for
TOEIC oh you were trying okay